good morning john ossoff is a man
heading into what could be
a seismic moment in american politics
one of the two democrats
hoping to take senate seats from
republicans and secure total control in
washington
good morning everybody georgia voters
have never had
more power than you have today
and this is a state one so republican
read thank you for voting
appreciate but now up for grabs the fact
this race is so close what does that say
to
the world do you think it says that
we're on the cusp of a historic victory
in georgia
we're on the cusp of delivering for the
people of georgia and for the american
people
the voters here are now younger more
diverse and there's a mood of change
the purpose for me was to vote so that
we could have an
impact where we can now put our
differences aside
and come together as a nation and do you
think that's possible yes i do believe i
do believe that's possible
if we have the right people know for the
right people in office and the right
temperament
we could come back together it's going
to take some time nothing happens
overnight
all the the riots and the picketing and
all the stuff with the police force and
all that i think they all played a big
part in
georgia turning blue to everyone that's
in my area and that i have in my life
is really just pushing forward to you
know having happier times and
not necessarily getting back to normal
because normal wasn't the best before
but hopefully
like moving to a better place it was
georgia of course that helped hand joe
biden the white house
he campaigned here knowing this election
will determine what he can actually do
in office
donald trump also came to town for his
last rally as president
there's no way we lost georgia there's
no way
that was a rigged election still
claiming he actually won
here his name's not on the ballot but
his record is
republicans right now are looking at it
and saying november 3rd was uh
was a rebuke on donald trump but but we
as republicans did just fine
if this election goes in favor of the
democrats even with one seat
that is a huge statement and a huge
issue
for republicans on the eve of congress
rubber stamping biden's win
it's georgia a game that will point the
way to where america heads next
greg milam sky news atlanta